over time the oceans would start to take
over our land
gradually dissolving coasts and then
making its way to our houses and
eventually our cities
and since this was all caused by global
warming which increases the chance of
hurricanes imagine these acid Waters
flooding our streets
if that were to happen our homes
buildings and Roads would all start to
dissolve and fall apart and it would
inevitably make contact with your skin
causing it to burn yeah swimming in this
acid would be out of the question and as
this happens more and more millions of
people would become injured or die and
the oceans would start to take over the
Earth
anyone who managed to survive maybe up
on a Mountaintop would eventually be
left with nothing
[Music]